blog mans numero 14 altrimenti il
battezzato giornata di panico ci sono
c'è la sfida con luigi di farci a
dicembre il maglione più brutto che si
potesse io non ho idea di cosa fare
quando ero a fare dei giri nella
speranza di trovare dell'ispirazione
direi questo è il posto che preferisco
entriamo
[Applauso]
preparata vizi ma poi sono super preso
delle luci dell'albero perché vorrei
farlo illuminato spero di trovare quella
di quelle batterie ma ho trovato quello
con la presa non è che se poi attaccano
presa pia fuoco ok sono tornato a casa
mamma tutta questa roba qui sembra che
io abbia svaligiato
non lo so l'albero azzurro ho un negozio
di tra queen o la melevisione baba che
sono tutti un po sinonimi se avete
seguito tutti i blog ma sapete che io
luigi abbiamo tutti e due
un maglione uguale io dovrò decorare il
solito per decorare il mio non sanno
fare appiccicare tutto questo
sopra questo avevamo detto che dovevamo
creare dei maglioni inguardabili
ma credo che c'è per tutto per questo ci
vorrà veramente veramente talmente tanto
coraggio per indossarlo zucchero cosa ha
comprato due piatti piccoli disturbi con
anima
il metallo campanellino perde pagare
eventuali biglietti questo cd rossi
cerchietti piccola ghirlanda pensavo di
fare un albero di natale con delle luci
qua e mezzo vedete dei pacchi sotto a
quel punto metterei una stella che
peraltro trasformata in stella di cometa
perché è più trash così è tutto quello
che rimane che ne so anche tipo fanno
ancora tipo questa roba gay e questo
nastro omosessuale questa è la cosa che
vi dicevo glitter comunque sempre molto
maschile comunque che dire questo è il
progetto lo so un po pretenzioso non
verrà benissimo ma bene non è tra i
requisiti di questa sfida
io partirei con la ghirlanda come per ma
roba da ricchi ray con il festoso quindi
andiamo lì giri l'idea in testa cielo
dovrebbe tutto liscio
a parte adesso fatta in realtà ne ho
ancora street e da fare è tornato delle
cose dell'albero di natale che abbiamo
fatto qua che non ha usato e quindi che
butterà dentro perché sarà una specie di
cous cous di tessuti è un disegno fatto
per denunciare quanto il cambiamento
climatico stia facendo male alla natura
e'avvenuto l'idea geniale bene ed era
mostrato cioè spiegare bene un po
difficile non riescono a parlare anche
perché sto tagliando da bravo una
schiena non riesco a fare le cose
contemporaneamente o che ho messo tutti
i pezzi sopra la stoffa e mi avanza così
giusto
per dare un'idea si fece farò non lo so
dei blu con col quale avvolgermi quando
sarò morto ci farò la mia sindone questo
è il risultato devo dipingere fare
visione visione visione movimenti
circolatori anche non rende come se
stesse nevicando ancora cioè vabbè
quelle cose avete presente quelle cose
che tu vedi non hanno senso ma sono
belle
[Musica]
adesso ciò che voglio è solo un bacio
cosa fare mi sono già pentita che poi
uno si chiede ma perché tutto sto brucio
di te che luigi molto bravo quindi
secondo me stativo creando non lo so una
specie di maglione di dior per natale e
quindi e sto cercando di creare almeno
un maglione teletubbies capito per
essere un minimo decente e adesso lo
devo tipo ti curare decorare e decorare
e decorare commentate commentate
commentate un'idea è quello di staccare
tutti questi dai cerchietti e cucirli
perbene alternandoli il bagliore
alternandoli perché saranno rendine e
babbo natale non è vero alberi natale
che holy see da qualche parte di
recupero applichiamo le resine speciali
sono cioè fatto
ecco dunque scusatemi il filo ci siamo
un po torca rovesciato tutto per terra
noro un buon bicchiere d'acqua battuto
sto macello fallire pulire con il
passato il muso da un po può valere come
mocio si accendono si accendono perfetto
che alziamo le grazia molin piazziamo le
commentate commentate commentate c'è una
parte di me che vorrebbe provare a fare
una cosa propone di pentirmene tagliare
e poi venire i cavetti ma se toppo mi
sono con luci chiediamo la mandi buona
blu fatto fa che sia semplice in quel
modo fa che sia come mi insegna un mio
nonno ti prego ok ho esposto il capo
aspetta non ho tagliato ancora in più
che deve essere tranquillo e sereno
tranquillo e sereno tranquillo e sereno
non mi sento tranquillo e sereno ti
prego ti prego ti prego accendi ti non
si accende ragazzi fermi tutti fermi
tutti ho scoperto che per niente si
possono accendere anche senza e se si
toccano si spengono lui andrà in giro
con un giubbotto antiproiettili
praticamente mettiamogli dei pon pon
però negli stacchi lo farà questo come
tutti i maglioni natale praticamente
resistere fino alla fine della serata e
poi c'è è viva consumismo tenenze
fortuna che ormai il bisogno di domani
per fare questa operazione non sono
molto bravo a riprendere
cerchiara resterò insomma le ghirlande e
posizioniamo in questo modo e con degli
spilli li blocchiamo in questi punti
devo batterlo ragazzi devo batterlo che
ce la farò con fissato le reni né le
ghirlande però secondo me la ghirlanda
va decorata su in cima campanellina
festone verde con l'anima di metallo
quanto mi piace dire a lima di metallo
la stessa lunghezza per lato dito detto
ciò in questo modo è anche un fiorettino
carino questo vi faccio vedere dove lo
posizionano definiamo all'interno
facciamo di girare sotto
allora ho preso un secondo in mano il
maglione e credo che abbia più o meno il
peso di un cane di piccola taglia però
sposare le maniche non li mettiamo dei
pallini e gli aggiungiamo tipo del rosso
mentre diamo le maniche evitiamo di fare
l'effetto do rio de janeiro pochi perché
poverino già questa roba qui in mezzo
allora permettetemi di illustrarvi no
qui non ci riesco scusate per la ripresa
già nota
allora qui abbiamo una manica abbiamo
una manica che che sfuma dal rosso verso
il bianco che poi si unisce credo al dub
le tasse non è dubbio falsa avanti
avanti e retro mentre invece qui la
manica sta sul verde perché quello è il
braccio destro che è colore rosso
questo è il verde del grinch perché la
sinistra rappresenta satana il male come
tutti sappiamo noi mancini e che anche
lei
sfuma col bianco e poi si va con
giungere a questo tripudio tripudio di
colori e di oriente forse gli farò anche
il colletto
nola il colletto poi diventano troppo
beh sì poi diventa troppo e che certo
rischio in questo gioco di equilibri
mi piace lo piazzato un altro fiocco
l'ho praticamente fissato con i piccoli
bolchini mi stavo chiedendo in più o
meno queste maniche di campanelle
considerando che è tutto così forte sta
povertà
riempiamo richiamo un crane io ho più
preso anche le maniche
forse in questo quantità basta che
dietro e anche qui io mi sono scusato il
retro definisco quest ok ho creato
questa piccola sacchetta interna per
metterci dentro l'interruttore lo
spiegherò in modo che non si capisca
nulla
aspettate clicchiamo lo mi sono appena
reso conto che non si può piegare questo
maggiore perché l'albero praticamente
rigido smt un braccio dentro ti graffi
con la colla a caldo che si era appresa
è diventata tipo non so fil di ferro
interno vabbè tanto non doveva indossare
io che mi metterò sopra una boccata per
fargli capire che un regalo per lui le
coccarde rischia di staccarsi vabbè anno
infatti i suoi o anche l'asso nella
manica o meglio la vittoria in tasca
pronti
23 che supercar in io pretendo quello
indossi per tutta la scena è anche il
pacco l'abbiamo fatto il ragazzino
finito speriamo bene
io sono contento soddisfatto eccolo è
arrivato con due nuovi amici ha fatti
mia cugina del posto cosa ci ha esatto
ho donato anche questo per domani ma
questa è un'altra storia che vedrete
domani alle 14 sempre creato il momento
quando stare vuoi scoprire il tuo vai ad
ora mai il tuo a sinistra quindi devo
guardare e cioè a destra e su quella
sedia girano no ma è un posto bellissimo
ma è bellissimo lo sto scherzando
c'è una piccola sorpresa mettitelo prima
metti però che indossavi provvederemo a
destra perché non l'ho indossato su
tossico flora amore c'è un interruttore
dentro e poi pure metterla lampeggiante
se vuoi
è fregato ma posso dire una base per
andare in giro
no complimenti aspettavo più gravi si è
impegnato da dio bravo ci ha pensato ci
ho pensato ma appena l'ho voluto fare
perché ho detto che volevo che tu avessi
la perché non si è riuscito a trovare o
posso dire una roba ed è super al
fratello non sul serio pensavo fosse una
pacchianata realta ti volevo mettere
delle delle piume tutte quante colorati
con delle palle che lo facciano sei tu
che adesso il mio taylor tu mamma
ragazzi già c'è una presentazione di
gran classe posso dire io abbia presente
il solito ho fatto di una pesa una sedia
perché un'acca era loro culture
[Musica]
l'unico sfilano prima cosa tu in quanto
hai fatto questo se in quattro hanno
fatto quelli non il mio è tutto cucito a
mano i tuoi sono tutti incollati amore
ma serve una prostituta bellissime voci
diversi colori grazie ma siamo per gli
istituti e due
comunque non siamo andati troppo intenso
siamo state comunque composti e anche un
po coerenti c'è sistema vicini non
sembriamo totalmente diversi no cioè si
ed equa che subentra la domanda alla
domanda è la seguente chi ha vinto ha
vinto il maglione con l'albero che così
almeno non facciamo errori il maglione
con la bere a chi è che ha fatto
guglielmo per lui o in maglione gaga no
oil meglio negata che ha fatto lui per
me fatecelo sapere nei commenti
cioè ma che sono senor moon ci vediamo
ragazzi domani
guarda già video la resa che a questo
rispetto a questa povertà ricchezza ci
vediamo domani alle 14 ciao
sei stato dire la compatta tutto sto ben
di dio per fare un albero di natale vi
facciamo così questo è lo prendo io e il
mio lo prendi tu
a